[Music]
[Applause]
I mentioned we were going to have Jeff
Perlman on he's been on before New York
Times best-selling author and uh the new
book the last folk hero the life and
myth of Bo Jackson he joins us on the
program
what made you decide you were going to
go all in on Bo Jackson
I mean I'm a nostalgist when it comes to
sports probably like you are when I
think about sort of my childhood on my
wall the Bo Jackson poster with the bad
overs in my college dorm at the
University of Delaware the poster with
him in the different you know uniforms
I think he's mysterious I think there's
a legacy there that hasn't really gone
sort of a deep dive and I did some
fascinated by him I'm fascinated by
everything about that guy and have been
for a long time you know I have the Nike
campaign I have the baseball it's over
here on the wall Beau just do it and I
don't know that how old that is how many
decades old that is but I I I remember
getting it and this is with the baseball
and the football with Bo and those great
commercials that might be 35 years old
but it feels like everybody has a Bo
Jackson story
or they've heard a Bo Jackson story were
you is part of the challenge kind of
sorting through and say that's that's
real and that's not real yeah definitely
and also allowing a little bit for the
mythology of it all you know like there
is a certain
you know like he um his his first he
played uh the first night game in
University of Georgia baseball history
and they put in the lights and they
brought Auburn's junior year of baseball
and everyone kept telling me this story
they're like Bo Jackson Hit the Lights
with the Home Run Bo Jackson Hit the
Lights it was crazy and I'm like and
this is 39 days before the natural came
out I'm like there's no way Bo Jackson
hit the light that's stupid well Bo
Jackson Hit the Lights he was playing
right field they were booing him to Hell
his first step out he grounds out
they're mocking him in the Outfield his
second Abad he comes up against a
pitcher named Larry Lyons University of
Georgia hits a ball that slams into the
light fixture falls to the ground he
jogs back out to the Outfield I swear to
God damn this is true they're bowing it
his next two at bats Dan he hits two
more home runs his last at-bat he
doubles and they boo him true story 100
true not on tape
how much interaction did you have with
Bo very little so I uh when I was first
working on the book I sent him a copy of
some of my other books I wrote him a
note he uh called me
we spoke for about a half hour he was
incredibly nice
he told me you know a lot of people have
reached out to him over the years it's
not his interest to write a book he
doesn't really want to be involved so I
think I really lucky
um you remember Bo knows Beau the
autobiography everyone remembers that
book so that was written with dick shaft
before dick shaft passed away he donated
all his notes and all the audio
recordings to the Auburn library all of
them they've been sitting in a basement
for 30 years and I was able to acquire
them and it's basically hours and hours
of Bo Jackson talking to Dick shap most
of it never used I also interviewed 720
people just a real sort of Deep dive
into the guy but why do you think he
said no
he's very guarded he's very reluctant I
think athletes of that generation a lot
of them think like this guy's just
trying to make a buck off me or this
guy's just trying I mean I get it you
know a lot of these athletes from that
era feel like they were taking advantage
of I think his legacy is is worthy of a
deep dive biography I think people
should remember him I think my kids
should know who he is but I 100 get it I
never regret someone I always wondered
this certain guys love sports love
playing a sport some guys are just good
at it they don't love it they're just
really good at it you know Andrew Luck I
don't know if he loved it he was just
really good at it and then I always
thought with Bo
did he did he love football
or did he he was just great at football
but he loved baseball
he loved track he loved track like he
loved track at Auburn he was a great
great Sprinter he would have been an
Olympian there's almost no doubt about
it skill wise he was there I mean he ran
a four one three forty in at Auburn he
he liked football he liked some of the
elements of football he liked baseball
more than football he liked the pacing
of baseball the camaraderie of baseball
but really he was coming he was showing
up the stadium he was doing his job he
was leaving I also just want to say Dan
he shows up with the Raiders and they
they actually are skeptical of his 40
time so Tom Flores is a coach and he has
him run a 40 on grass in pads and he
runs a four one nine they don't believe
it they have him do it again on grass in
pads 225 pounds he runs a four one seven
he ran it better the second time you
wait his first major league at that his
first time he usually got about
September 2nd 1986 uh Royals uh White
Sox he hits a grounder to second base
Tim Hewlett he beats it out
3.6 seconds it is the fastest record a
second fastest recorded time ever from
home to First for by a right-handed
hitter it's his first at bat the only
guy ran faster top uh tapewise was
Mickey Mantle yeah I remember that oh
that's a joke I do love this story when
Bo got brought up to the Royals because
he was coming up and that was a veteran
team you had some you had some crusty
old veterans there tell the story when
Bo you know first goes into the locker
room well he shows up it's like so tone
deaf it's fantastic with a stack of
glossies of him with the Heisman Trophy
and he he signed them all and went
Locker to locker and left them on the
seats thinking like Frank White and
George Brett what they really need in
their lives is an autographed picture of
some 22 year old and Hal McRae was a DH
in his last year with ours and he goes
around following Beau and he takes the
pictures and starts throwing them up in
the air and everyone starts throwing
their own pictures up in the air and
George Brett looks around and he like
takes four of them and hangs him up by
his locker everyone else just Chucks him
away he was arrogant but now that he was
cocky he was confident he was not
arrogant he was very confident
I had an opportunity the first time I
interviewed him he had won the Heisman
and uh I was working at CNN sat down and
did an interview and and he had a really
uh bad stuttering problem and and so you
didn't really know about him what you
knew is what you watched with boat and
he wasn't effusive he and I kind of
careful in in what he was saying and how
he was saying it but I later on I played
golf with him and Jim McMahon oh wow and
Beau putts one-handed yeah and and and
he was great because I let McMahon and
Beau talk because I being a reporter or
journalist I did I wanted them to just
have fun so we were playing a round of
golf in in Chicago and I just remember
Bo punting one-handed
and I asked I said why are you putting
one-handed he goes well look at how well
you put two-handed oh that's awesome and
I was like oh okay but he but he was
telling stories back then whereas you
know he probably wouldn't have done that
if it was just me and you know somebody
else but with McMahon McMahon was able
to talk talk to him and get him to be a
little bit more forthcoming wait dan you
know you know how we you you and I in
the in the in media we come across
certain guys who aren't really good for
us but we admire them because we
understand that they're actually like I
remember doing a story years ago Sports
Illustrated 70 to do a piece on Paul
kanerko the White Sox first baseman yeah
and I showed up in Chicago and the guy
said to me I'm just going to be honest
with you I don't really want an article
on me it's nothing against you I just
don't really want that like I'm pretty
happy right now and I'm living my life
and I just I don't need five pages in a
magazine about me I'm good and you're
like oh man I just flew out here but you
also kind of admire it and I feel like
that's Bo Jackson a lot of ways like
everyone's like oh it's such a shame
your career was cut short he's like I
don't see ashamed you could have been in
the Hall of Fame I don't really care
like I don't I don't care and I kind of
admire that in fact very much admire
that about the guy he's not out there
comparing himself to Derek Henry he's
not out there saying you think this
guy's good you should have seen me I
could have been my show never never ever
ever and it's one of the most beautiful
things about him what's like John
Stockton John Stockton we'd get to the
NBA finals and NBC would be begging John
to do an interview and he just had I
don't want to do it that's not why I
play I play to play not to do these
interviews what did you find out about
the hip injury with Beau
well it was first of all the Raiders
really butchered it at first he was
basically you know just debilitating hip
injury and he's on the sideline for most
the rest of the game he's in the in the
locker room after just kind of hanging
around talking he went to Buffalo next
week when they lost to the bills 51-3
when he finally got a scan of the hip
um
there was a huge black mark on the scan
and the doctor says Bo do you know what
that is and he's like no he goes that's
your blood pooling in your hip and
he um you know he had just signed he
right after that hip injury happened he
insisted everyone I'm going to be fine
I'm gonna be fine I'm gonna be fine the
Royals signed him to a two million
dollar contract and that was big at the
time oh yeah and they thought he was
going to report to Spring training and
be okay he reports the spring training
on these purple crutches and he goes to
our uh to uh George uh Alabama to see uh
Frank Andrews Dr Andrews to get a look
at the hip and while he's in Alabama the
Royals release him
because they're they're either going to
be on on the on the books for two
million dollars or they're not and
they're just like you're not going to
come back from this you can't come back
from this it is impossible for you to
come back from this and the thing about
the Royals their advantage point John
sure holds hard Stewart they didn't want
him playing football from the beginning
and they said from the very beginning
don't do this don't do this told his
agents don't do this he insisted on
doing it he was mad at them after they
released him but I don't really see what
option they had and then he got an
artificial hip
well first he played here's the crazy
thing 91 he signs with the White Sox
everyone thinks it's a joke a gag White
Sox just getting some publicity points
he comes back at the end of that year
playing without an artificial hip and
basically limping along and he's not
awful but but he comes back for spring
training in 92 and it's a really sad
there's a sad moment I wrote about in
the book he's playing he's limping all
over the place he hits a grounder in a
spring training game to short Cecil
Field is playing first for the Tigers he
holds his hands up to Alan trammo saying
don't throw the ball don't throw the
ball because they're so pathetic
watching Beau limp down the line he
didn't want to embarrass him he gets a
hip replacement comes back in 1993 why
it Sox make the playoffs he hits a huge
home run to get him there against Dave
Fleming in Seattle
we're talking to Jeff Perlman uh the
book is a great book to pick up the last
folk hero the life and myth of Bo
Jackson you also wrote the Brett Favre
book and then everything that came out
you sent out a tweet I believe saying
basically don't buy this book if you
haven't bought it don't buy it
um did you see any of this coming
I feel like in a way we all did this
wrong we in the media I won't speak for
you but I'm saying like um
when he sent that this is going to sound
according when he sent the pictures of
his you know private parts to Jen
stergers a sideline reporter I feel like
Brett Favre should have been dead to us
all like that should have been enough
you know like what kind of person does
that and we we so we always fell for the
Gunslinger Swagger he's a gunslinger
look he's coming back with the Vikings
my book was a hard look at him it was
not a glorious look of Brett Favre
but I still think did I fall for this so
the reason I sent out that tweet the guy
allegedly
took money he's from Mississippi this is
your Steed it is the poorest state in
the nation people need welfare money to
survive and you and the governor are
funneling welfare money
to pay for a volleyball Arena a year
alma mater that you could afford I
always think like did you learn nothing
from your career from the diversity of
sports from being around guys from
different backgrounds you've certainly
played with guys who grew up in largely
African-American communities who grew up
on welfare who grew up with hard-working
parents who needed help did you learn
nothing does that just mean nothing to
you and I was so Disturbed and so
disgusted I was like don't buy this book
don't waste your time reading about this
jackass yeah
all right my guys want to pitch you your
next book
love it okay in all right uh Paulie I'll
start with you give me your elevator
pitch for Jeff I think Larry Bird is one
of the greatest athletes of all time I
think his the story of his youth there's
a lot of stuff there about Bob Knight
and going to Indiana was he uh was he uh
doing garbage and he's found at a pool
and all this stuff with Indiana State
his family his father there's a lot of
people people outside of Indiana don't
know his background and I think a really
detailed book would be fantastic hasn't
that already been written with him he
was he wrote Bob Ryan uh drive with Bob
Ryan yeah okay Seton what's your pitch
well this is another athlete who
seemingly has endless legendary stories
about him probably more humorous than
anything because the dude was just like
a walking I don't know just one line
after the other but John's hit in 316
Ricky's hitting 330. Ricky Henderson I
could the stories about him are just the
absolute best but I know there have been
a couple books about him but I feel like
there's got to be more stories out there
all right wait Derek I just say yeah
Howard Bryant released a book probably
five months ago called Ricky it's a
tremendous tremendous biography it's
literally sitting on my desk it's over
there that's why I was saying Howard
wrote this already and you can still
have another one uh Todd what's your
pitch my pitch is if not the brothers
then we focus on Sterling sharp Seven
Seasons he was on to Major greatness had
the neck injury personality maybe not
quite as much as Shannon sharp but I'd
be looking I'd be interested in a deep
dive on Sterling sharp I think it's a
little tunic
yeah then we'll do the Wesley Walker
biography
one eye he's my kind of guy uh Marv you
got a pitch for Jeff
you know what the business of LeBron
James with Rich Paul Maverick Carter the
entire thing from the jump I'm sure it's
probably been written about but Jeff
like the showtime book was ridiculously
good so just a real deep dive into even
the Cavs
no I got you kissing up a little bit oh
yeah I'm sure I'm talking Lakers it was
great uh Jeff what what are some of the
ones that you're thinking about
I actually have been talking at length
about just with friends about Larry Bird
as a possible I think there is a great
Larry Bird biography to be written you
know their last book was I think was a
Bob Ryan book when he was still playing
hold on one scene okay what about uh
UNLV late 80s early 90s there's some
stories there UNLV
yeah I think it's the thing is I always
I'm being serious like the question is
like is there a mass audience appeal
I'm not saying there isn't but are
enough people got a bite on a UNLV book
are the names big enough tarkanian maybe
Larry Johnson Stacy Ogman
I just don't know for sure someone's
saying this and gamblers and you know
wait let me ask you guys I'm being
serious someone pitched me an idea or
said to me the other day you should do a
book about Edie's wrestling like WWE 19.
it's not a horrible idea right well you
know you're gonna have you know a mass
audience that are going to be interested
in that absolutely what Marv you want
another pitch I'm switching it no no
the urban Maya Florida Gators teams
marvelous that's not bad that's pretty
good that's pretty good uh all right I'm
in I'm in you're in you guys pay me Dan
Patrick press well are you gonna you're
gonna get 30 minutes with Urban Meyer
because he's probably not going to want
to talk about this I just go to the
barriers and hang out with the wow
interactive women wow look at that shots
fired did you hear what Pearlman said
about Urban Meyer
good luck with the book uh it it and
it's one of those fascinating guys that
you're right he didn't say much I don't
know how many great interviews you
actually heard but the stories about Bo
told by other people that's what makes
it so much fun because they tell it in a
way where you're not going to believe
this but and then you believe you
eventually believe it when you know they
back it up I do just want to say he hit
a baseball in a game against Fairfield
High that went so high that the left
fielder by the time it came down Bowers
rounding third base and I thought that
was ridiculous and I talked about 12
different people from that game and they
all told me the same story so maybe it's
not true
but maybe it is but didn't you talk to
the pitcher
I talked to I did talk I don't know if I
talked to the picture from that game I
talked to the left fielder who caught
them oh the left fielder okay I talked
to the pitcher from the game against
Georgia oh okay uh hey thanks for
joining us always great to talk to you
Jeff thanks Dan that's Jeff Perlman New
York Times best-selling author the uh
last folk hero had the showtime Lakers
he's doing well on a roll